[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey show where we help you win in
your life specifically your money your
work and your relationships the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
I'm Ken Coleman and joined in Studio by
my colleague and Ramsay personality
Christina Ellison Christina this is our
first time in our little duet here so
this is very exciting yes are you ready
to sing I'm kidding I'm kidding no
singing today I don't know about it yeah
no I couldn't do it if I tried because
my voice is trash from allergies and uh
I might have gone to a piano bar at our
Austin event last week and sang too loud
and I don't know if it's recovered since
I I might have I am so sad I missed that
yeah well believe me believe me we're
gonna need a repeat so oh boy well let's
get to it the phone number as I said is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Brielle joins us in Sarasota
Florida Brielle how can we help
hi
um so I am newlywed I'm 25 my husband is
turning 28 this year and uh we recently
bought a house we owe 400 000 on it uh
we make gross 150 000 a year and I have
a very large stretch goal of paying off
our house in about five years by the
time I'm 30. so I wanted to get your
opinion on if you think it's okay if we
were to pause contributing and maxing
out our Roth IRAs so that we could put
that money towards our mortgage and pay
off our house within our goals well I
love this goal I love that you guys are
so excited to pay off your house by 30.
that is so so exciting
um but I am I am wondering so would that
be pausing all retirement you wouldn't
be contributing anything you would just
be putting everything on the house
correct So currently I have about 55
000 in a Roth IRA and my husband has
several thousands um in his Roth IRA and
we don't have 401k we just currently
contribute to Roth IRAs
um so we would be stopping that okay
well I I can see the Temptation and it's
like I don't want to kill your
motivation because that's super exciting
that you're stoked about it but I we
have the baby steps in order for a
reason so retirement is going to come
someday even though you know it seems
far out at 25 years old but the
beautiful thing about investing for
retirement right now is it's going to
build compound interest over time and it
is just amazing when you look at the
retirement calculators and you see if
you save aggressively in your 20s what
that's going to be in 25 years that is
amazing and the house is great but we
also want this money growing at the same
time so I would not say to pause your
retirement I would keep investing 15
like baby step four you know doing the
baby steps in order and trusting the
process now on the flip side of that if
you still want to hit it by 30 I would
encourage you to start being creative on
different ways that you can get more
money to add to the house so I don't
know is that 150 is that just your
full-time jobs or is that side hustles
yes yeah yeah we um we are both
venturing into side hustles as well so
between that and the increase in our
salaries we you know they'll continue to
increase over the next years to come for
sure so I would challenge you to take
what you were going to get from that
retirement investing that you wanted to
throw at the house and make that money
additionally try to earn that money
through side hustles and see if you can
get that extra money to throw at the
house so you can still do both so you
can still invest towards retirement and
also hit that amazing house goal that's
right embryo Christina's right and
you're going to come out better
financially if you walk out the baby
steps and that is going to look really
really beautiful when you've been
investing that entire time that you've
been attacking paying off the house and
you you wake up on the other side of
that one morning and you did what
Christina told you to do and now you're
on your way to being truly an a baby
steps millionaire and that's why Dave
wrote the book baby steps millionaire so
I'm going to give that to you as our
gift just to reinforce uh what Christina
told you so hang on the line we'll get
you copy of Dave's best-selling book uh
best excuse me baby steps millionaire
and this is going to reinforce and give
you that Clarity that you need so that
you're not tempted because on paper it
seems to make sense but we want you
winning completely so thank you so much
for the call all right let's go to Ali
in Baltimore is it Ali or Ali do we know
it could go either way thank you all
right Ali I was right I am Hooked on
Phonics today very exciting that those
courses paid off Baltimore Maryland Ally
how can we help
um yes so my husband is transitioning
out of the military
um just got a new job and it has a very
high deductible insurance medical
insurance
um we have about a thousand dollars in
credit card debt that will be paid off
this month and we owe 7 000 on our
vehicle
um we currently have the money from our
tax return to pay off the vehicle in
full
um but I'm going to be having a baby
this year and our the medical deductible
is five thousand dollars
um that will have to pay before the
insurance kicks in
so I'm just wondering if we should save
that money since we know we're going to
have the medical bills coming
pay off the medical bills and then
continue to pay on our vehicle or just
pay off the vehicle and then work on
work on the medical bills as they've
come well congratulations on all of that
is this the first baby
at third oh okay you're an old Pro yeah
and also very busy yes and tired
well that's all very exciting um so
you're in what we call stork mode so
this is the time where it is okay to
pause the baby steps and save up money
because yes you need to be able to cover
that deductible and we don't want you to
go into more debt for that so
um yeah this is one of the very few
times we would say to pause the baby
steps but
um you're in that season and you know
that money's coming you're going to owe
that money for the birth and so taking a
pause as weird as it feels right now
because it does seem like you guys have
been super motivated with paying off
what you have and the thousand dollars
this month but just for this temporary
time yes we would say pause
okay very that's gonna help me sleep
better at night
and of course once you're past this
phase I can I it feels like you're
motivated you've been motivated we'll
want you to pick it back up that's you
know some of the dangers uh of pausing
at times as you know keeping that you
stop the momentum Dave talks all the
time about momentum theorem so you know
don't let this be something where it's
like you stop it and then you forget and
then you get into mom mode and you're
exhausted postpartum and you know and so
on and so on but for now yes take time
okay enjoy prepping for that sweet baby
coming yes and then get back on it and
you know it's really fun to hear Ali's
shoulders drop right there when you just
kind of you know it's like she didn't
need permission but what's great about
this process for those of you that are
new to the program and you're hearing
this and you're going how do we take all
of this baby step stuff and how do we
apply it as real life happens and this
is a great example and you got a mom
right here going okay
I could still be disciplined get out of
debt but I got to take care of that
deductible and now I can sleep at night
and that is really the piece that we
talk about so much here
with the baby steps leading
to Financial Peace So to that in if
you're new to the program you've been
listening watching for some time and
it's helping you and encouraging you and
you think that it could help others will
you help us spread the word subscribe
review and share because we want to help
as many people as possible learn how to
handle money so they can live and give
like no one else she's Christina Ellis
I'm Ken Coleman don't move more of the
Ramsey show coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 off everything site-wide
go to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back America you are listening
to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken Coleman
joined by my colleague Christina Ellis
we're here for you this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
take in your calls of course about money
but also about your work and your
relationships and I'm the Ramsay
personality that's dedicated to work
simply put I believe that everybody
wants to make a difference they want to
make their Mark professionally it has
tremendous personal benefits and the
science proves that and so I want to
help you discover and do that work that
you were born to do and that involves
walking through getting Clarity on what
that is how do I get qualified to do it
and with Christina in here today we'd
love to take your getting qualified what
do I need to do from an education
standpoint
to be able to do the work that I want to
do it's a great little combo today and
we're going to talk about that this
segment because Christina on on the Ken
Coleman show
I get this question all the time someone
calls and they want to Pivot to
something or they're thinking about
pivoting and they are immediately going
do I need to get another degree because
I can't afford it right now or I don't
have the time or
the combination of both and what I love
about what you're doing and what I'm
doing is we dovetail together very well
and so we're going to walk through some
common questions in this segment because
I think it'll help people begin to take
this big giant scary
unclear destination and begin to go oh
wait a second
I can actually get there and I can get
there in a non-harmful way yeah right
meaning not sucking all my time out and
thus hurting my family or
uh spending money they don't have in the
form of a student loan yeah and that's
what I was going to say is that I talk
to so many people who chose to go to
grad school because maybe they were
confused about what to do next in their
career or maybe they felt like that was
just the next step and so they went to
grad school without really thinking
through it deeply and then you know they
may have avoided debt and undergrad and
then took on a bunch in grad schools I
think it's really important to ask some
hard questions before you just decide to
go to grad school because maybe it's the
right decision but it may not be so yeah
I kind of wrote out some questions
hit me with the first one this is really
good question one okay so if you're
thinking about grad schools The Next
Step okay one question you should ask is
is this just a check mark we took a call
from somebody I think it was last week
or two weeks ago where she was thinking
about getting an MBA because she told
she had a professor tell her that that's
what she needed to be successful in
business that if she just had an
undergrad in business then she wouldn't
be successful so she needed to have that
check mark in order to have the right
opportunities now mind you she was
already working in a job that was
business related and really loved it and
didn't actually want to get the degree
but she felt like she had to right in
order to be successful so so I gotta
jump in here because this is the kind of
stuff that makes my blood pressure get
to unhealthy levels
um but we live in a world
where I could say the Sun is hot and
somebody wouldn't misinterpret that so
listen very carefully some of you who
are
borderline snowflakes and you love
education so much you can't hear
anything else how's that first setup
we live in a society
where this example this call you're
talking about is the norm where a
professor said to a young lady in order
to be successful in business and maybe
run a business one day you need to get
an MBA well that is a big crock of crap
there are good things that you can learn
while pursuing an MBA but the reality is
you can take your shiny new NBA
Christina and you are still going to
have to get in business
and learn business by following first in
other words in order to be a good leader
you must be a good follower well I got
to tell you something the only way to
learn how to be a good follower is to
actually get in on the ladder and begin
to work your way up they're not going to
teach you how to be a good follower in
an MBA program right and you can learn a
lot of great things but it may not be
necessary and like with this girl she
was going to go to an MBA program that
had no track record that's right it had
no history it was just simply here's why
the narrative is you get the NBA and
you're gonna be you're going to be more
successful because they're going to pay
you more but here's the thing you can
take your MBA but you're still gonna
have to get out there and compete and
beat somebody and I will take the kid
who doesn't even go to college at all
who starts out in a small business and
starts in a grunt job and works his or
her way up the ladder
I'll take that person every day of the
week and twice on Sunday I would that's
me because you're MBA doesn't prove
anything to me other than you were a
good student right so for some people if
you want to get an MBA if you can afford
it that's great and for some careers you
do need grad school but make sure you're
asking yourself before you go to grad
school is it a check mark another
question is is there another way to get
the training you need yeah and I know
you talk about this a lot there's a lot
of people getting master's degrees and
phds and like digital marketing and
maybe they could have just gone through
a certificate course on how to do social
media like is there another way I think
this is good and you know you and I've
talked about this a lot I have a
two-part question that allows us to get
to the heart of what Christine is saying
here and it's this is it the only way to
do what I want to do in other words if
you want to be a doctor or a lawyer for
two very simple examples you have to get
the undergrad degree and you got to get
the grad degree that's just the the game
has been defined for you now you got to
play by the rules but by asking that
question is it the only way what if we
get a no it's not the only way now the
secondary question is is it the best way
and so now we can actually look at it
and go oh if it is clearly and
statistically socially culturally
whatever the best way then yes go get
the degree but do it the way that
Christina teaches you to get it let's
pay cash yes and that's the next
question is can I afford it no boy can I
afford it there's not as much
scholarships and financial aid for grad
school that's just a fact but that does
not mean that you should get student
loans if you've got to get student loans
then you can't afford it so you know you
can either wait and save up you can find
a cheaper program you can apply for
scholarships and fellowships you can use
tuition reimbursement programs there are
ways to pay for grad school but just
because it's a little bit harder doesn't
mean that you should just throw caution
to the wind and just take on debt and
another question is is this actually
what you want to do long term yeah I
really encourage people don't go to grad
school just to find yourself like that
is such an expensive way to do that I'd
rather you go to Italy and Eat Pray Love
for a few weeks you know rather than
spending thousands of dollars on an
education that you're not sure about hey
I'd rather you I'd rather you spend
thirty dollars at ramseysolutions.com
and get my get clear career assessment
whoa why don't you just get self-aware
for a moment why don't you read my
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose yeah and actually explore and do
what I call clarify and verify if I
wonder about being a nurse here's an
idea
why don't I sit down with some nurses
in all walks of nursing you got your
labor and delivery nurse you got your
emergency room nurse you got your
pre-checking here's what we're saying go
get some actual information with your
head Christina and here's what I found
that when I go and I clarify what is
involved in something that I am
interested in one of two things will
happen
I will verify that yes I want to do it
or I will verify that no I don't want to
do it yes but instead of finding
yourself to your point over a very
expensive and arduous graduate degree
why don't you hang out with some people
who do it and find out The Good the Bad
and the Ugly and your heart's going to
tell you yay or nay that's so wise it's
sad because I've met so many people who
have fifty a hundred thousand dollars
and student loan debt from grad school
and they're not actually using that
degree oh and they're dealing with guilt
right they feel like they have to stay
in the career for five to seven years I
hear this all the time because they feel
like they have to justify the degree so
you're now imprisoning yourself
over Pride but what are people going to
say and so take the time to do the
legwork on the front do the legwork do
the do the assessment get clear before
you start and then one more question is
this is a hard one because I know a lot
of people who are feeling all the feels
about grad school and they love
education they're not really going to
love this question but ask Will it Roi
does it make Financial sense to go get a
grad degree will you earn more in your
career does it make sense to actually
one invest what it costs to get the
degree so let's say for example it's
forty thousand dollars a year to go
through a two-year master's program so
you're paying eighty thousand dollars
just for the program and then if it's a
full-time program you're taking two
years off work so you're let's say your
salary is fifty thousand dollars that's
a hundred thousand dollars that's a
hundred and eighty thousand dollar
investment is that worth it will it Roi
it's hard it's hard questions it may be
worth it but ask it explore it it
exposes the nonsensical cultural
pressure
that has been fed to us through great
marketing
oh you're smart you're successful if you
go get that degree oh it'll it'll pay
off it'll pay off
the evidence says not always it might
encourage the ask the hard questions
first all right don't move more Ramsey
show coming right up
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today okay
and set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
the Ramsey Show continues from our
Ramsey Solutions worldwide headquarters
in the shadows of Music City Nashville
Tennessee I'm Ken Coleman Christina
Ellis joins me this hour we're here for
you taking your money questions your
work questions how about your getting
qualified do I need a degree how do I
pay for it is there an alternative
we'll take your work questions as well
and your money questions around getting
qualified in the school area Christine
is the expert there and and I'm the work
expert so we love to combine on those
questions so parents as we are in
literally uh the lead up months to
millions of Americans Christina walking
across the aisle uh are actually the
platform rather and moving the tassel
which way does the tassel go it's been
so long for me I can't even remember
gosh I don't remember either I feel like
it's on the left and you move it to the
right but I probably said it wrong it
doesn't matter it's a very exciting time
for parents but also a lot of anxiety
yeah right where's my kid gonna go some
kids are still making those last minute
decisions
um and so uh we want to help you so
special call out to you parents or young
people or even adults who are thinking
about pivoting let Christine and I walk
you through that process today Triple
Eight
825-5225 all right uh speaking of time
flying and things happening in the
spring uh we're just two months away
from the smart conference actually
inside of two months now my goodness uh
the smart conference weekend which is an
extended smart Conference of those of
you that have been to our events before
or the smart conference April 14 and 15
right here at the brand spanking new
Ramsey Event Center here on our campus
Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney
George Campbell Christina Ellis Jade
warshaw and yours truly are combining
for what will be a powerful weekend
uh it's our first event at the brand new
event centers I mentioned and we're
gonna do some fun things
um and uh it's a weekend long event
so every ticket includes a commemorative
badge by the way that's a hard word to
say
uh try to say commemorative more than
once in a sentence it's a tough one I I
got through it there your phonics are
still working thank you thank you very
excited and throughout the weekend
there's going to be a lot to do
um chances for you to get a book signed
get pictures with all the crew we're
gonna have some incredible live music
because it is Nashville so you don't
want to miss this a few tickets left and
there are only 119 each again for a
two-day event Friday afternoon into the
evening and then Saturday so don't wait
go to ramseysolutions.com
events that's ramsesolutions.com slash
events and grab your ticket today gonna
be fun gonna be fun all right let's get
to Louisville Kentucky Brandon is there
Brandon how can we help
hi I was hoping for some help with a
tiebreaker between my fiance
I love this I I don't shy away from this
I've got a vote I just don't know which
way it's going all right set us up what
what is the case essentially
um we're talking about where we would be
moving to after we get married which
would be uh in the upcoming summer and I
am thinking it's a good idea to rent for
at least one maybe two years so that way
we make sure we're stable like uh job
positions all that kind of uh situation
but she is really excited about buying a
house and I don't want to be someone
that like destroys their dreams because
yeah long term I think that's the right
decision but I'm not sure if it's the
right decision today because she's just
um like she's going to be getting out of
school this year so she still has that
like work
I leave full time with her career path
and all that all right so let's do this
before Christine and I weigh in because
I'm already ready to vote I'm already
ready but it's based on on Stacy and I's
Journey so I I'm a bit biased so let's
look at the facts and get the emotion
out of the way that means on your side
and her side like because you're a
little bit worried a little
protectionary she's excited she wants a
nest I mean that's a normal thing so
let's remove the emotion let's walk
through the numbers do you guys have
debt separately and walk us through if
you do
no we do not have any debt so no debt
and when does she graduate
he graduates on May okay and what kind
of money does she think uh she's going
to be able to make
uh she's told me probably around the 40
000 a year is what uh Horizon and what
do you make
I currently make 80. okay nice oh I like
six figure uh double income no kids
Hello uh we can make them some real yeah
is that what they call it I forgot the
Dual income no kids oh it's very
exciting uh and uh do you have any money
saved either one of you separately what
do you each have saved
oh like we both live pretty frugally but
I'm a little bit more of a investor in
my size so it's like on cash yeah I have
probably about
10-ish saved she probably has around 40
say so it's like down payment wise
combined that's not as much of a problem
how much of that is allocated for the
wedding or is that not going to be used
uh well he wants to just do a courthouse
wedding so basically zero hey can I just
tell you if she wants a courthouse
wedding as a dude you need to go oh yeah
babe I mean yeah and if you're the
Frugal one like I mean that's great
every guy I know would pass up the
frilly weddings for the courthouse yeah
yeah no that's that's the plan yeah all
right well that's great news okay so uh
what size house is she let's be honest
here what is she looking at what are we
talking about prices like I'm trying to
keep things below like the 300 ish Mark
and is she good with that but that's
like I absolute Max for me like my goal
would be probably closer to the 200 or
at least under 250. oh I know what does
she want what does she want she was the
very top of the budget
whatever I think about everything that
she really like so what is she thinking
600 500 what are we talking about uh
well not really that far because for me
it's like it's more of just thinking
about like technically if you look at
what we can afford probably more than
what I'm capping it out as but for
thinking about the future like I prefer
it to be under 250 but right those
things that you really like the future
closer to like 300 ish Mark okay and
y'all are you moving towns or are you
going to stay in the same city you're in
right now
um staying around the same uh area that
we're in right now okay you already have
jobs after graduation everything's set
up
she does not it's like I I've been
working full-time for a few years now
it's just like I don't have like I have
no problem with that but she uh she
doesn't have a job all right Brandon I
gotta ask you this real quick so we can
render a judgment uh um I
how much of an argument is this I mean
is this just a playful when you say
settle the tiebreaker is this is this
digging some heels in on both sides or
is it just we're expressing our
preferences and we're not on the same
page yet where are we at relationally on
this
oh it's not like a huge argument or
anything it's more of just from her and
yeah I think it's like a really big
excitement so it's partly like it's just
going against that so it's difficult all
right Ken's just making sure we're not
gonna start a fight tonight yeah yeah
because this is I'm aware that you could
roll this back on YouTube and I kind of
want you to I want her to watch this I
want Christina to weigh in because I
think it's fun that we got the male
female opinion here I don't know what
you're gonna say what say you okay this
may surprise you okay I'm on Brandon's
side I would wait so am I I would wait
you and I are in agreement okay yeah
there's so much transition happening
just in general when you first get
married it's nice to have a little bit
of time to rent yes Dave often says to
figure out how far you want to live from
the in-laws yeah um it's gonna be your
first time living together and really
seeing each other's preferences and all
of that you don't know if you like what
you want in a house exactly you don't
know how that's all going to match what
floor plan you want
um and just in general like 50 000 is a
good amount to have saved up like that's
I'm glad you have that but you do you
still have a wedding ahead that part of
that's going to be your emergency fund
so that doesn't leave much of a down
payment I know you do still have time to
save but with the house that she wants
it sounds a bit like she would feel like
she was settling if she got the house
now I agree and while they've got 50
collectively 60s that 20 down payment at
the top of his range right and I just
know from experience the dude's gonna
land a little bit closer to what mama
wants that's just the deal and so what I
would say is I'd rent a minimum of 12
months and let's see if we can go above
and beyond let's have that emergency
fund yes that we go into marriage with
let's get a fully funded three to six
months of emergency fund based on your
two incomes and let's save the down
payment above and beyond that let's rent
for a year two years you're not throwing
money away you're just getting settled
as Christina said and you're not
destroying her dream you're delaying the
dream to do it the right way I'd ever
watch this back so that we can be the
bad people but hey you're good dude
Brandon congratulations this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman Christina Ellis joins me this
hour it's a free call to jump in
888-825-5225 that's
888-825-5225 and I want to say a big
thank you and welcome to all of the new
listeners and viewers who join on all
the different platforms you know of
course we've got talk radio SiriusXM
podcast wherever you listen to your
favorite podcast and then YouTube is
exploding as well and so if you're new
and you're hearing things like baby
steps and which one and all this kind of
stuff a lot of jargon you're not used to
we've got you covered go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button
and it's just a couple of quick little
questions that kind of gives us an idea
of where you are on your financial
Journey why you're listening and
watching the show and kind of those pain
points and then it's going to plug you
in uh so that you begin to understand
where you are on the journey that we
call the baby steps the seven baby steps
that lead to Financial Peace So it's a
great way to really get plugged in
ramseysolutions.com and click on get
started all right let's go to Ryan in
Erie Pennsylvania Ryan how can we help
yes so
um I'm Ryan
um I've recently gone through a divorce
um I'm so sorry so how long ago how long
ago did that happen or finalize
yeah it got finalized last month okay
um I've been going through it for a
little under a year now so
um
yeah so just kind of restarting uh now
and just trying to figure out where my
Financial Focus and kind of my goals
should be at well can you give us a
picture of what your financial reality
is uh do you have any debt what's your
payments as there may be a result of the
settlement
absolutely so I'm only 25 so we didn't
have any kids
um
um my income I make about 90 grand a
year right now
um my student loans I have about five
grand left student loans
and I am left with the house in my name
and there's about a hundred twelve
thousand left on the house okay
and no other debt
no other debt my my vehicle is paid off
good for you so how how are things in
the divorce right now is it finalized is
it still kind of ongoing
yeah it is everything is finalized as of
last month
so
um everything is paid for in the divorce
so I'm done with that and just kind of
ready to move forward now all right so
that's a nice uh nice situation in that
you can get out of that student loan
pretty quickly are you planning to do
that
yes so
um I have a little over 10 grand left
after everything right now
um in cash I figured I could in Cash
correct pay the loan off today
okay while we're in this new season
let's go ahead and pay that off I mean
today like within five minutes of you
hanging up this phone call
call the bank call the student loan and
let's get it paid now you're left with
5K in cash and the only debt you have is
your house how familiar you familiar
excuse me are you with our baby steps
um so that's kind of the approach we
took when we first
when we were first when we were ready to
get married and we kind of snowballed
our debt and then after this all
happened that's
um we're snowballing kind of our student
loans and I'm left with five grand left
so I'm fairly familiar with the with the
baby stuff so here's the deal you pay
off the 5K today you had any challenges
with that you okay with that you
understand that's the play right
yeah I mean you make good ones there's a
little bit of worry having five grand
left in the bank but I just I just
started a new job actually dude you're
25. you're 25. you have no expenses you
have no kids you could you got this is
not an issue and you're making nine
Decay a year like you got a good income
nothing to be afraid of right
yeah all right so that puts you that
puts you 5 000 into what is your three
to six months emergency fund and I can't
think of a better way to to kind of come
out of a divorce than to just get some
type of really serious personal goal and
your big time personal goal is Financial
in getting baby step three done and get
that emergency fund fully funded How's
that gonna feel just from a financial
standpoint
yeah correct how quickly could you do it
be realistic
um
a couple months a couple of months and
now now you got the emergency fund and
now it's getting your your retirement
set up and investing set up at the age
of 25 Christina yeah that's incredible
I'm also curious how much Equity do you
have in your house what's your house
worth
um a house worth about 140
000 maybe 150 000. because I'm also just
getting excited with the fact that you
only have 112 left on the house so it's
like you're gonna have this fully funded
emergency fund done in a few months
you're going to be investing for
retirement and I think you can pay that
house off pretty darn quick probably
within if if you're really serious and
this is a big goal for you you could do
that for sure within five years I would
say oh easily I'm even thinking if you
got really gazelle intense uh not that
you have to beat yourself intents and
four through six but if you really
wanted to knock that out like you could
have that done quick and can you imagine
being under 30 with a bait with a paid
off house on baby step seven
yes that would that would be great
definitely now do you plan to stay in
that house or do you want a fresh start
because the other side of this is
uh you know you could sell it if it's
got bad mojo right and bad feelings and
all who knows I'm just being realistic I
mean because you now have an opportunity
where you can completely
start fresh financially and walk through
the baby steps pay that house off you
have no debt and after we're investing
that 15 since you don't have kids you're
moving towards a house down payment to
where eventually hopefully you meet
another person and give love another
shot and now you're just moving forward
and just much better financial position
I would not be opposed to you selling
your house given that situation but as
Christina said if you don't need to get
out of it it's a great asset that you
can pay off what are you thinking what
are you feeling yeah
um
I understand the the bad mojo part and I
really was considering at first I'm
doing a little better now good so I'm
okay with staying here at the moment but
the reason I want to stay is I I've put
a little bit of equity in the house and
my mortgage is pretty low so yeah that's
a no-brainer incredibly low so yeah it's
a no-brainer I just wanted to give you
permission that you know you were in a
position to start over if you wanted to
but I love the play and I love what
Christine is telling you just get
gazelle intense let me give you
something to focus on as you heal and
you're making great financial progress
which means you're making great personal
progress coming out of something like
this yeah
I'm so sorry for what you're going
through because it's like I can hear it
in your voice it's just it's so much
pain but financially you're doing really
well and I think especially in a couple
years you could be in a really really
great spot so
um I'm excited for your prospects in the
future the fact that you're still so
young and you can be killing it
financially and also still reach
whatever goals you have if if you want
to have a family or just whatever
personal goals you've just got a lot of
time but we're going to gift you a copy
of own your past change your future
which is Dr John deloney's book that's
good hang on the line Austin will pick
up and that can just help you process
the grief because I think that's your
biggest challenge right now money wise
you're you're doing great yeah like
you're gonna the sky is the limit for
you you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire if you take this advice
today and you just walk the plan like
you're going to be rocking it in your
30s but I think right now the biggest
thing is just really working through the
emotional sticky messy hard stuff and
Ryan do you have have you connected with
one of our smartvestor Pros in your area
I haven't no all right I really want you
to do that I want you to
um after we give you so we got some
homework assignments uh hang on the line
Austin's Gonna Get You John's book own
your past change your future you are
um also gonna hang up and you're gonna
pay off that five thousand dollars on
that loan and then you're gonna go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the
smartvester pro button Christina because
I want him to interview three or four
smart master Pros in this area because
he's already uh needing to have these
conversations because he's going to have
that emergency fund fully funded in two
months which means we want to make sure
that at 15 in baby step four of his
income is being invested wisely because
at the unbelievably young age my
goodness of 25. uh he is on his way to
being a baby steps millionaire so those
are your homework assignments Ryan we're
so sorry that you're going through this
tough time but I want to tell you
something my friend Joy comes in the
morning you're in a storm right now
you're coming out of it and it's gonna
be okay so do those things and I think
you're going to look back many years
from now and say hey
um the best is still yet to be she is
Christina Ellis I'm Ken Coleman I want
to thank our team James Childs our
fearless leader behind the class that
keeps us all in the air I want to thank
you America for listening because this
is about you this is your show it is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Ken if you love the show and
want a deeper dive on your money Journey
we have a Weekly Newsletter that gives
you trending and helpful articles and
tips on following the Ramsey win go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solution broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman Christina Ellis is my colleague
and joins me this hour the phone number
is free to jump in on the conversation
because it is about you
888-825-5225 that's
888-825-5225 so Christine and I here
together and while we take those general
questions we also love to team up in our
specific areas of expertise Christina is
a true
unbelievably knowledgeable expert on how
to go to college without going into debt
she's the best selling author and
working on some really fun stuff that we
can't wait to talk about uh in the days
ahead in the days ahead and then I'm
helping people specifically win in their
work life
so if you feel stuck or you feel scared
you feel doubtful you're dealing with
some toxicity horrible leadership and
you're just looking for some help and
some ways out we're taking those
specific calls today as well let's get
started with Alan and Chattanooga
Tennessee Alan how can we help
how are you doing we're living the dream
what are you doing
maybe about six months all right that's
exciting yeah
congrats but yeah that's sorry it's a
fourth one so
busy oh fourth yeah you're exhausted
aren't you Alan you sound exhausted
not a little bit about to look nice too
so it kind of make it all a little bit
worse say that again you broke up
I work nice as well so it kind of makes
the exhaustion even worse oh bless your
heart okay I get it all right well how
can we help today
well I'm wondering with the bid becoming
about six months I have the cash to pay
off my home
and it would leave me with about fifteen
thousand dollars in in cash as well for
backup
for and I was just wondering if it would
be wiser to go ahead and pay it off now
or to wait till after the baby was born
in six months
that fifteen thousand dollars is that
your fully funded emergency fund or is
that over and above that
uh that's an emergency thing okay is
that fully funded like it would that be
about three months of your expenses or
six months where does that fall
uh if I lost my job I can go I can cut
expenses back to about fifteen hundred
dollars a month
and so it could last me six months if
the house is paid off
okay and if it's not paid off about how
is that about yeah about three months
three months maybe okay and how much do
you have left on the house
I have 54 500.
man I'm just excited for you the fact
that this is even a question that we're
not in in store mode and talking about
like oh man what do we do and all this
is great
I mean it's one of those situations
where there's not really necessarily
like a wrong answer but we do typically
recommend whenever there's a baby coming
to kind of hold off and hold on to cash
because there's a lot of things that can
happen unexpected expenses I mean we're
talking about quite a bit of money and
paying off a house
um if I I think we just kind of have to
frame it in the sense of if I were in
your shoes if I were in your shoes I
would probably hold off until the baby
was born or at least just do a portion
especially with the 15K left that would
make me a little bit nervous that I
wouldn't want to have a really flush
emergency fund I'm also curious so with
the expenses
um how much are you anticipating the
birth is going to cost and any expenses
around baby
uh I estimate about four thousand okay
and how much are you making right now
I'm like 49 a year
49 a year and and you said you have four
babies at home
before this will be number four and as
your wife does she stay home or what's
kind of the rest of your family
situation
yes yeah I'm always a stay-at-home and
that's part of how we get our extensions
down uh yeah I'm excited how did you
save up the 54 has it just been
diligently saving it up and or did you
have the vision to pay off the house why
did you save it up and wait till this
point versus kind of paying it off
incrementally
well a lot of it was just being sure
that you have in the cash emergencies
and stuff like that and
it just kind of just budgeting putting
things aside and building growth you
know for like office expenses you're not
getting very happy to be best or
something of that nature
so that has built up over time yeah let
me just clarify real quick did you say
5400 or 54 000
54 000 54. okay so this is a good amount
of money wow yeah Ken I'm curious to get
your opinion what would you do I'd sit
tight
um and just wait until we got through
the baby yeah I agree with you I I think
you could you could put maybe a little
bit extra on but I would sit on the cash
until we get through baby number four
and uh at that point
um I would then start to attack it and I
because I want you to have that fully
funded emergency fund so if if it's me
you said you owe 50 on the house is that
right
oh you owe 54 and you've got 54 in the
bank
I have I have enough I have
I have enough to cover all the way the
whole house and still have 15 000 left
over gotcha yeah you know what I'd
rather you do I'd rather you I'd rather
you get to where you had the enough to
cover the house which is 54. and then
six months expenses once I have that
number so 54 plus you understand what
I'm saying
yes then I would pay the house off I
just I don't want you you're just so
close you have so little left on the
house you're in great shape your single
income another baby on the way I don't
think that's what I would do but again
as Christina said there's really no
wrong answer here but I I would limit my
risk and I would get the fully funded
emergency fund plus the payoff now but
here's the deal
you don't have to wait so let's just go
let's fast forward to baby coming I
think you said in six months baby comes
baby's healthy we got the 4 000 in cash
to pay for the birth
um then I'm gonna go all right what's my
six month emergency fund number right
and let's just say it is uh let's say
you got uh he's got plenty in the bank
he's got 50 so so let's say the number
is uh thirty thousand all right
um
because I don't want you cutting way
back just to scrim so let's just say the
number is 30. okay and the payoff of the
house is 54. you don't have to wait to
get to 74 to pay off the house what I'm
really wanting you to do is build that
emergency fund yes and let's get that
but we can start but we can we can start
putting more once we get the emergency
fund which you've already got
essentially right now so now I'm going
whatever the six-month emergency fund
number is
subtract that
and I would put whatever's left
after you've got that I put it on the
house after the baby's born like day one
what a celebration right like babies
born and let's say we put 20 grand on
the house you know but we still got a
fully funded emergency fund now we only
have and I'm making this up thirty four
thousand dollars or whatever left on the
mortgage and now we attack that but I
just I because you know we want him on
babies at five right we won't be moving
towards the kids he's got four kids
saving you know that's your that's your
ammo so like what's what's he doing
there so play that out because we got
kids that may want to go to school yeah
well and it's like one I do realize like
once the house is paid off then it's
like that six month emergency fund may
just be fifteen thousand dollars so
that's going to that is correct feel
really good it's just I know even with
the fact that you waited until you had
54 000 to pay it off I do feel a bit of
anxiety around money and making sure
things are secure so I don't think it's
really going to hurt to wait six more
months but just when that six month Mark
comes
get that house paid off that is so
exciting so amazing amazing uh what what
a wonderful story of a man taking care
of his family congrats on the baby
congrats on the baby and making 49 000
y'all so everybody who's listening who
doesn't have a student gotta run
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
show continues I'm Ken Coleman Christina
Ellis joins me this hour
888-825-5225 is the number it is your
show America we're talking about your
money your work and your relationships
888-825-5225 we'd love to hear from you
let's go to Los Angeles California Josue
is there Josue how can we help
hey Karen Christina thank you for having
me on the show sure what's going on
uh just a quick question so I'm
restarting the baby steps for the second
time and I'm getting a tax refund of
four thousand five hundred dollars and I
have a car that's the definition of the
Dave car the windows don't work the AC
is always on hot the hood doesn't stay
up and I've done a few repairs to it but
I'm not sure it's going to last me so my
question is if I should purchase a new
car that's a little more reliable and
actually more economic because this
thing has a V8 and it just sucks a lot
of gas uh if I should buy a car that's
more reliable and economic or you know
put this towards my one thousand dollar
emergency fund and I can actually pay
off a couple of credit cards with the
remainder
well let's zoom out tell us a little bit
more about your situation you said
you're starting the baby steps for the
second time what happened the first time
so the first time I was in a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars of debt
um and actually I found you guys after I
filed for bankruptcy
um which kind of felt like I got off a
distance lap in the wrist so I went and
did it again
uh I got loans and credit cards and this
time though I was involved in a
motorcycle accident I broke a couple of
Bones I was in the hospital for a week I
was unemployed for three months so all
of these loans now I'm feeling the
weight of it the debt now is less but
it's still pretty significant it's forty
thousand dollars of debt um
and so I'm kind of you know I just I'm
I'm frustrated I'm mad sad and
disappointed at myself so I just kind of
said you know what it's time to just
settle down and take this step seriously
so
um I said enough is enough I got a new
job I'm starting doing the every dollar
budget app you know like give every
dollar a job and I did this refund I got
this surprise refund that I wasn't
expecting and it could you know kick
start my baby steps or help me buy an
interview how much was the refund
4 500.
hey good job good job the fact that you
have been through what you've been
through I know that was hard and there's
probably a lot of Shame with the first
time round and and getting back into
debt but good job coming back around and
saying you know what I've had it that's
it I'm mad and this time it's it and it
feels like that you know my question was
going to be have you had your I've had
it moment but it sounds like you have is
that correct
yeah I have you know with all those uh
members calling me while I was in bed
and I couldn't you know even walk
um I was just mad at the banks they were
gonna make uh you're asking me for my
payment and I can't even walk right now
and it really a little fire underneath
yeah well let's go okay let's talk about
this car so if you sold the car you have
right now the V8 what do you think you
could get for it
yeah yeah you said it's it's a it's on
its last breath so it's probably not
gonna be a lot what about with the new
car that you're looking at new used car
what are you looking at as a budget
um looking at a budget probably no more
than 3 000 you so that I can have that
starter emergency fund okay good so
you're taking the 2000 from the car
you're selling and then 1 000 from the
four thousand dollar refund and that's
what you're getting your car with is
that correct
uh yeah pretty much I mean like I said
at the 2000 is probably like at the
extreme end of you know selling it at
the most that I can because I bought it
for three it's a 2004 Ford uh Expedition
um so yeah the gas the gas trouble is
real like a V8 like that's that's a lot
of money you're having a hard time
keeping the hood down or you can't keep
the hood down how do you keep the hood
down duct tape what are you doing
alternator issues that I need to replace
um I have some time to start it with a
dump starter and uh so I I'd usually
just use like a broken if you keep a
broom to keep it up yeah let me tell you
something the alternator is it's about
to die and at some point you'll get to a
point where you can no longer get it
going so this is uh this is a legit
emergency because I'm guessing you need
the transportation to do your work
correct
yeah I go to work and for in the morning
so to 3 30 and then I go to school from
5 PM till 10 pm
yeah well Christina if it's me I'm I'm
going to uh get that emergency fund baby
step one funded through this and I'm
going to go get another car just so he
can get back on his feet because you're
telling me you paid off 130 000 using
the baby steps
he did not intervention
I was bankruptcy yeah oh I missed that
okay I was wondering how you got away
and you're like I paid it okay never
mind so so dude like you gotta you gotta
take care of you on this car because
this car is uh the key to you being able
to to do your job right
yeah but but I'm in your shoes I'm not
taking the four thousand dollar refund
and the two thousand dollars from
selling the car and buying a six
thousand dollars no like what I would be
careful walking onto the car lot and
getting tempted to go up in price like
I'd still be getting another Dave car
like just one that the hood stays down
and that doesn't cost you know 200 to
fill what's the alternator gonna cost to
replace the alternator so the alternator
is pretty cheap it's only a hundred and
thirty dollars and I could do it myself
but you know the car just have so many
little things like the windows won't
roll down and right now in California
it's cold so it's not a problem but
during the heat you know the windows
okay here's why I'm asking that I'm
uh because I'm saying I wonder if I
could get two or three more months out
of it because two or three more months
will make a big difference in this
process would it not
it would
I'm gonna try I think I can definitely
get that Hey listen I'm jealous because
I can barely put gas in the car I would
love if I could change an alternator up
trust me I'd do it and I put it on
social media to brag about it okay but I
I I if it's me I'm going to hustle
and grit my way through this
and I'm going to change the alternator
I'm going to nurse this car for two
three more months
um and then stack up the money that's
Christina that's what I'm doing I'm
gonna keep this baby alive I like that I
don't think you got a shot in the world
of getting two grand for this car and
that's why I'm saying that so at this
point we're gonna nurse it until we take
it to the graveyard I that's what I
think
that's good yeah make it last as long as
you can because walk that out for him
financially if he gets two or three more
months out of this what how does that
play out well how much are you making a
month how much are you able to put
towards debt like once you're in this
journey fully what's your income
so I make 27 an hour which is roughly
about 56 of them a year fantastic
I'm getting about 16 to 1700 a month and
I'm lucky enough that I still um I rent
a room for my mom's house so I'm only
paying 500 for this rent out here in
California that's like
per month
I'd throw it a bit like 2 500 a month
there we go so we're looking if you can
make it another two months that's five
thousand dollars yeah yeah it just helps
with that refund and getting a head
start on the debt snowball yeah I'd
nurse that car for a couple two three
more months as long as possible and and
walk the baby steps out in the meantime
and I just want to encourage you too
like if you drive around Ramsay our
building we have people who are walking
out the baby steps and we have some
hoopties in this parking lot we've got
some things that are duct taped together
that are you've got zip ties like we've
got some real special cars out there
because people are motivated and they're
getting it and they're trying to do the
same thing they're like hey if I can go
two to three more months then that's
five thousand dollars that I can put
towards nobody cares what you're driving
if you're embarrassed by it I get it
just park around the corner and walk
tell somebody you ubered I don't care
I'm okay with the white lie on that one
I don't care uh you know I mean it just
doesn't matter in the grand scheme of
things I remember picking Stacy up for
our first date Christina in a Mazda 626
this was in 97 it was an 82.
and it was such a piece of crap that I
could pull the key out of the ignition
while I was driving as a trick and just
showed people including her oh oh it was
bad I like 350 000 miles it's a miracle
that she married me she's just she is
she's a beautiful amazing woman with
horrible judgment but you know the point
is is that it just doesn't matter you
know the car the car is if it gets me to
a to to B who cares if it smokes a
little bit lurches a little bit and it's
a little sweaty
you know power through it it's gonna be
okay hey Josue thank you so much for
calling you got this young man you can
knock out this debt in no time flat and
it's going to be the best decision
you've ever made thank you so much for
joining us here on the program thank you
America don't move more Ramsay show
coming right up
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back America this is the Ramsay
show where we help you win in your life
and your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman and I'm
joined by my colleague Christina Ellis
for Ramsay personalities glad to be with
you today
888-825-5225-88-825-5225 is the number
okay today's question of the day comes
from Shane from The Ramsey Baby Steps
Community oh boy Christina now this is
intense
should I give up my apartment
to live in my car and use gems to shower
and use the gym bathroom to save enough
money to buy a house cash now there's
gazelle intense and then I don't know
what this is this is the beyond the
gazelle this is beyond the gazelle and
this isn't even we're not talking baby
step two gazelle intends this is paying
off that house I'm gonna live in my car
and I'm gonna use the gym in the
bathroom I mean excuse me the shower and
the bathroom at the gym to make it by
I would say absolutely not yeah I agree
I I think it's great the motivation to
pay off the house we've had some really
motivated people calling today wanting
to pay off houses which I love that I
don't want to put a any water on that
fire at all but I do feel in that
scenario that's just a little bit too
far right yeah I think so it's not first
of all
I don't feel like it's very safe no
matter where you live
right like like Franklin Tennessee is
like Disney World okay what Walt Disney
tried to do on Main Street we have that
for real yep it's a low crime area okay
and just being real it's wealthy but I
wouldn't tell anybody to sleep in their
car in the safest community in America
whatever that is wherever that is well
and my husband's retired police he was a
police officer for 17 years detective
did all sorts of roles he's in the lobby
today would you recommend anybody he's
saying no he's shaking his head now
I've heard way too many stories and way
too many crazy things that have happened
in safe areas supposedly safe areas so
and just even beyond that like we want
people to be gazelle intense and baby
step two but when you're in four through
six we're wanting you to be intentional
and there's just a lot of Ripple effects
even just to Your Ego to your well-being
to being able to have people over to
just different things when you live in
your car and you're technically homeless
like that's just that's just not where
we want you to be we want you to be
intentional now on the flip side of that
if you want to find a really cheap way
to live that's great yeah I am all about
like seven or eight roommates sure uh
but that's extreme too but let's not
live in our car plus you'll stink
plus you'll stink you know what I mean
let's just be honest that's nobody needs
to experience that so there you go
appreciate the question there uh there's
a much better way to do that okay
um this is fun Christina I've got a CNBC
article in my hands and the headline
reads the 10 worst pain college majors
five years after graduation okay so this
data comes from the New York Federal
Reserve
and what they did is they studied uh
Majors uh for for people right out of
college their first five years and so
this is pretty fascinating stuff all
right and I want you to comment away
here all right because this is near and
dear to our hearts yes uh because I
don't want you choosing an education
that you can't use or that you shouldn't
use all right and she wants to make sure
that you pay cash for it and we don't go
into debt so here we go
um let me make sure I got this right yep
number one uh worst pain major
Theology and religion oh now let me just
tell you something I'm gonna I'm gonna
do a little commenting here
thirty six thousand dollars is the
median now these are medians all right
so it's not the average it's just taking
the high the low right in the middle so
there we go
median 36 000. now let me tell you why
this is crazy even in religious sectors
this is like a bait and switch Christina
because they'll say all right
um You got to have a masters of divinity
or maybe a doctorate if you want to kind
of go higher levels and teach theology
now if you want to be a pastor you don't
have to have a masters of divinity you
really don't
um and you could probably get in a lot
of church staffs just with a just with a
basic degree and go in and start as a
youth pastor but you're going to work
that hard that long in a four-year
degree and you're gonna come out and
make thirty six thousand well Ken we
took a call a few months ago from a guy
who had a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in student loan debt and he was
a pastor yeah good luck and he had he
literally called us and his baby was
about to go in labor or his wife was
about to go in labor she it was just man
it was devastating because it was like
that was not a good choice We love that
you're a pastor that is amazing yeah but
that's a lot of debt for a career that
doesn't pay a lot so it's be smart about
it there are still schools that cost
sixty thousand dollars a year that have
passed our programs that might not be
the smartest choice there's a more
affordable way about getting to that
destination that's exactly right uh next
Social Services 37
000 and again you go to school and you
come out and you're going to get this
job in a local government or a
non-profit setting and you're very
limited your financial growth just with
the four-year degree on Social Services
is right there there's not much room for
growth moving on family and consumer
Sciences that's in that same Social
Services area this is interesting
Christina psychology
37-4 because with a psychology degree
that's like being a doctor or lawyer
that's just getting you started you're
going to have to go get that master's
degree and maybe even the doctorate and
this is why it's so important to work
through the ROI equation I think when
people get a psychology degree they
think they're going to graduate making
psychiatrist money and that's not what
the four-year version leads to so think
through what that those prospects are
all right now here's my favorite and I
have personal story here Christina that
you don't know oh yeah it's very
exciting probably not Leisure and
Hospitality degree
a whopping 38 thousand dollars in your
first five years now Leisure and
Hospitality okay so that's your hotel
your Resorts that kind of stuff all
right so in college one summer I went
back to Hampton Roads Virginia where I'm
from and I worked at the Norfolk Hilton
and I had two jobs
I did room service
on Monday Wednesday Friday and Saturday
huh I made some good money by the way
because it's automatic 15 gratuity and a
lot of people are on business trips so
they're just tipping you extra had to
wear the little tuck shirt and tie
though there you go
and I got the tray the whole nine yards
and then I managed a restaurant
in the hotel on Tuesdays and Thursdays
now when the summer was over my manager
and the hotel general manager sat me
down and said is there any way we can
talk you out of going back to school
we'd actually like to get you on a track
for being a manager and move into an
executive role with the hotel and all
that I mean they're asking me this at
21. now here's my point
if you want to get into Leisure and
hospitality
can I just say you'd be better off going
and getting yourself a good job for a
nice chain or a really nice resort and
start at the bottom do a good job and
work your way up and you can work
yourself into management a six-figure
job and never have to darken the door of
a college now what say you on that
versus go for four years bust your butt
to make thirty eight thousand dollars
that's
that's automatic success that's right
and it's like that's not what's going to
make you successful the reason they
wanted you to stay was because you were
a husband you had aptitude for it you
were doing a good job so I think it just
it proves that but I love your example
too because it's like maybe you could go
work for a chain that has tuition
assistance so you could start working
you can get your feet wet you can have
your experience and you can get your
degree while you're on that track that's
really good rounding out the top 10
Performing Arts 39 000 early childhood
education 40 Elementary education 40
special education 40. and uh and then
miscellaneous education now in contrast
the highest paying majors are all in
stem Fields right an acronym for science
technology engineering and math the 10
best Majors five years after college are
mostly subsets of engineering so think
chemical engineering you know all the
different engineering tributaries if you
will and so please be aware that these
are the real numbers so not Christina
opinion or my opinion these are the
numbers and the numbers don't lie
and yet you've been told that that
degree is going to make you super
successful and Christina's right you are
the X Factor when it comes to that so B
be very informed and very wise about
these decisions because sometimes these
financial decisions can affect you for
decades and we don't want to see that
she's Christina Ellis I'm Ken Coleman
don't move
couple of commercials and we'll be right
back this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
yeah
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation here on the Ramsay show so
excited that you are with us paying off
debt is smart saving investing is smart
but there's one key to winning with
money that people Overlook all the time
and that's protection
protecting your finances from
emergencies and that's where insurance
comes into play now there are 10 kinds
of insurance coverage you might need
based on what your life looks like today
and we've built a tool called coverage
checkup
and this will show you which types of
insurance you need to add drop or adjust
we'll even rank your coverage list buy
importance email it to you and then
connect you with a Ramsey trusted
insurance provider so you can get your
plan in place fast this could be the
most important five minutes you spend
today by the way I've done this and it
really is five minutes or less wonderful
tool one of our listeners wrote in named
Donald he said for anyone who has not
completed this checkup do it now you
never know when something will happen
and you never want to leave your family
in a bad situation amen Donald
visit ramseysolutions.com
checkup that's ramseysolutions.com
checkup don't let an emergency sneak up
on you
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number I'm Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis is my colleague and she
joins me in studio this hour let's go to
Des Moines Iowa Gordon is there Gordon
how can we help
Hi how are you sir I'm uh well I've been
sitting here not literally but mentally
Sweating Bullets waiting to be able to
talk to you well you're going to do
great we're here to help how what's
going on it's just friends sitting in
the living room that's right
yep
um
well I
I don't know I I just kind of wanna
give you a little a little bit of my
story and see what you have in mind I
I'm 26 been married two years I we just
had a little boy
five days ago
um he is I'm I never thought I'd get to
say this but I'm a very proud father you
should be what an exciting time and
you're also tired as well so we get it I
am a little tired yeah we've been there
yeah
um
I guess my what I'm trying to figure out
right now we're going through FPU and
we're trying to nail out the budget okay
um
my question for you Ken especially is I
I don't really know what it means to
what a career means for me
um I don't know what
what I want to do with the rest of my
life yeah that's that's the bigger issue
you're not sure what that thing is that
work that you would love to get up for
on a Monday morning and get after it all
week well Ryan or do you I I I have some
I have some ideas give me give me the
top couple of ideas that you find
yourself wondering about
well
Gordon Gordon let me help you out
because I've done this a lot I've talked
to over 5 000 people on the Ken Coleman
show on this very thing and I've heard
you before you just had a different name
and you were from a different place you
cannot think your way through these
answers I don't care how it sounds it
doesn't have to be impressive I just
want you to share your heart because I'm
telling you you got some ideas and
you're struggling with a lack of
confidence and the answer to that is to
get you clear and I can do it if you
just rip the answers no more thinking
now give me the top two or three ideas
that you wonder about and you've been
wondering about go
I I do like working with people I like
creating and working with my hands okay
um I like to teach
I've I've been building over the last
several years I've I've ever worked to
the Scout camp teaching Boy Scouts
um I've built steel grain bins I'm I'm
currently a welder
um good
what do you like about welding
um
don't I don't think it's it's creation
yes it's I I like assembly I liked
taking all the pieces and putting them
together tell me about the tell me about
the people part I know that you're
creative and you like to create with
your hands that's very very clear by the
way and that's great I I love people
specifically like teaching people and
and like I I'm I taught swimming I
taught Boy Scouts how to swim and how to
canoe and I got to the point where I I
felt really good with it yeah and I I
was always trying new things and then I
got to teach these boys the basics and
so what if and a little more what if
Gordon what if I told you
that your career could include
creating with your hands
and teaching other people
to create with the hands what if it's
not an either or and I think that may be
what you're wrestling with is that right
or wrong I don't mind if I'm wrong but
tell me am I right I I absolutely agree
it's it could I'd love to mix things
together too can I give you can I give
you able to brainstorm what that might
look like oh this is exciting Gordon the
reason you have it listen Gordon the
reason you haven't been able to
brainstorm
is because you're so full of self-doubt
because you'll get an idea and no sooner
does the idea come out of your head
actually come out of your heart and your
brain then starts to go well I don't
know if I could do that does that sound
about right
let's talk about right yeah Gordon I'm
going to suggest to you that your head
and heart have a wrestling match maybe
on an hourly basis and so what we've got
to do is we've got that's true he said
we've got to listen to the heart all
right so the heart says I want to do
both
I want to create with my hands
so welding is a form of that you are not
limited to welding are you Gordon
no but it is in fact a way of creating
with your hands
but then there's this instructor inside
of you that just loves Illuminating and
encouraging guiding people isn't that
true Gordon
yes sir so here's one brainstorm idea
you're a qualified welder
you could potentially pick up a side job
teaching at a welding trade school true
or false
certified but yeah
I didn't say you could doubt with me on
the phone Gordon I'm going to ask the
question again Gordon is it possible in
this world
for you to get to a point with your
certain
that you could teach welding on the side
or maybe even eventually go full time if
it was a better gig than your current
welding position is that true or false
Gordon
yes sir it's true that's just one idea
how else do you like working with your
hands or may I ask where are you good in
working with your hands Wood
Construction give me some a couple other
examples where you're really good with
your hands
uh
uh just about every everything I've
tried exactly wow so what so so
well okay Gordon what is if I could pay
you
the desired amount of money that you
want to make
but you had to pick just one thing and
you don't have to do this in real life
but in Fantasyland right now we're
getting to the core of your heart if you
could only pick one thing one job you're
gonna get paid very well you're gonna be
very good at it getting to work with
people and you get to train on it as
well as a as an add-on what would be
that working with your hands type work
that you would just get excited about
every morning and lose track of time say
it don't think
um metal working uh great blacksmithing
great so you're in that lane with
welding and metal working that's all so
here's the deal let's go get certified
let's make some more money as a welder
let's look for an opportunity to teach
it in a local trade school even if it's
one night a week here's why Gordon
what's going to happen is is for the
first time in your professional life and
my goodness you're only 26 you're like a
child compared to me you're gonna
experience true love at work
because you're gonna go I get to build
and create and then I get to instruct
and relate that's your jam right
yeah all right then so are you waiting
for permission
because you came up with all these ideas
I didn't
I guess what I'm what I'm hoping for is
yeah permission validation but a clear
path forward okay here's the Clear Point
so I'm gonna all right I'm gonna give
you the clear path I'm gonna give you my
book from paycheck to purpose as my gift
it's actually the seven stages but we
got you clear right now now it's about
getting qualified you just said I got to
be certified to get the next level of
welding going so we're gonna get
qualified we're gonna get connected with
opportunities to teach and do this
welding work or iron work or anything
else we talked about today Hang on we're
going to give you the book from paycheck
to purpose Gordon you're gonna do it
buddy congratulations on being a new
Daddy get some sleep Christina Ellis
great hour James Charles and the crew
thank you guys for keeping us on the air
and you America for listening this is
the Ramsay show
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsey Show it's where we help you win
in your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman and I'm joined by my colleague
Christina Ellis
we're here for you this hour triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's get to the phones
shall we uh Yami is joining us in
Orlando Florida yummy how can we help
hey
um well as you know my name is Yami hi
everyone
um basically um I went to school
um a little later in life like maybe two
years after I graduated I had a really
good paying job I worked in a bank but I
had a passion to do ministry and I'm a
really good singer so actually my my old
youth pastor said maybe you should go to
school to become a worship Pastor so I
decided to go yeah I decided to go to
SCU at an extension site where I was
basically working full-time doing
schooling for time but they were
actually paying for most of my schooling
up until
um covet hit and during covid since I
wasn't able to work at the church
full-time I was having to take out a
loan and mind you I never ever wanted to
take out a loan that was like my biggest
fear but during covet I I absolutely had
to or I wouldn't be able to pay for
schooling
um so what ended up happening was that I
I didn't really read the fine print and
I made a huge mistake and it turns out
that that they had been placing those
loans on my account my student account
up until I graduated so then I was left
with almost ten thousand dollars of
student loans
um as well as
um recently I just in my taxes and I owe
like almost 700 because I was working
part-time at a preschool and they were
like a self-employed kind of uh deal so
now I owe money back anyway all of all
that to say I have a passion for people
and helping people and during covid I
was really depressed and I was able to
get out of that depression so my my
passions kind of shifted and I decided
that I would love to be a therapist one
day
uh
trying to figure out what's the smartest
thing to do if I should wait before
going back to school to pay off these
loans or if I should defer them or I
guess that's what it's called or
um and then just hop right into school
or if I should even get a degree at all
considering the state of the world and
inflation and yeah I'm just kind of lost
and I want to do is help people in my
life sure yeah well I'm glad you called
today and I think I think the very first
thing is kind of just slowing down like
I feel like there's a lot of kind of
Chaos in all of this especially even
with the way you got your last degree
and the confusion with covet and taking
out the loan and not knowing what's
going on and now wanting to shift and
not really sure I think you're heading
somewhere but we sometimes it's good to
just go okay let's stop let's stop and
be real strategic about this and I think
that's what you're doing with calling
today so I'm glad you did that so with
the degree that you got it was what was
the major
so I'm I majored in ministerial
leadership
um so it wasn't necessary
this is more just about biblical studies
and public speaking and Leadership
abilities and things like that plus I
got a minor in Psychology and it's
accredited so that's good so what are
you doing right now what is your career
at the current moment
right now I'm working at a Bath and Body
Works and I'm trying to find a job that
may be hopefully going to be able to pay
for the Master's Degree if I decide to
go that route okay I feel like this
conversation makes me think of what Ken
and I talked about recently about grad
school I think a lot of people go to
grad school when they feel confused they
feel like maybe their undergrad degree
didn't lead exactly to the career that
they wanted or it wasn't as easy when
they when they graduated they're they're
working in a job that they're not
wanting to stay in they feel confused so
they're like you know what if I go to
grad school then I don't have to
feel weird right now I can get an
education and I know I'm heading to
something and it just kind of like puts
a Band-Aid on it really I'm not saying
grad school is not the right decision
I'm not saying that it's not a good
thing but it's not the right decision
when you're trying to figure out when
you're trying to find yourself and
that's kind of where you're at right now
I think your undergrad degree could
possibly lead to a great job that you
really love you say you love working
with people and you want to help people
there's a lot of jobs out there that you
could get with a four-year degree but
you have right now without having to go
take on you know the the the
commitment and the time and the effort
of a grad degree and I know Ken you
probably have well strong opinion about
it I want to dig in here because if I
heard you correctly there was a season
where you were enjoying working in a
church setting a Ministry setting and
you also love to sing and so I'm just
curious I understand that you went
through some tough stuff during the
pandemic and when you came out of that
this this passion
um for being a counselor coming out of
your own depression I understand how
that presented itself so I don't want in
any way to minimize that so I want to
make sure you hear what I'm asking
what
changed about the music and the
ministerial position what changed
uh other than maybe what you went
through and then coming out of it and
and I just wonder if you saw a path
to where you could win financially
would that have changed your mind tell
me what you're feeling when I ask you
that
um well I just I started well my the
church that I interned at it was a
really like it was a bigger Church
um and even then I I
I didn't really realize that that
position exactly like being a maybe a
worship Pastor wasn't going to be like a
full-time thing
um or like something that I could make a
decent amount of money doing
um to survive I guess not only that but
um I just wasn't trained as well as I as
I thought I would be like essentially I
was placed where I was needed sure
because it was a big big organization
all right so for just the interest of
time this was not some burning desire to
be in Ministry long term this is
something you just kind of we kind of
fell into is that what I'm hearing yes
all right so I want to give it back to
Christina on this
um
but I would just simply say
if
you feel absolutely called and I'm going
to give you my get clear career
assessment to take it's about an
18-minute assessment I'm going to give
it to you for free I want to see if that
purpose statement and your results line
up with the therapy and it'll be really
clear but if that is in fact what you
really want to do and you know you have
what it takes to do it then let's delay
getting into that graduate degree until
you can afford it Christina yeah I'm
with you on that Ken and I also think we
should give her from paycheck to purpose
because I think there's a lot of like
feeling of lack of purpose right now
you're feeling confused and frustrated
that where you're working is not where
you envisioned and I think you can get
to a much better job that's more in line
with something you'd be excited about
and I think too you could work in a
field that maybe you do eventually want
to get a grad degree but test the field
first and so if I'm in your shoes I'm
not going back to school yet I'm taking
some time I'm taking the assessment I'm
reading Ken's book and then I'm finding
a job that's exciting to me right now in
this moment paying off my student loans
and then we can talk about grants that's
right it's going to be there Christina
her grad school opportunity in her
future will be there after she gets debt
free and that's what we want for you
yummy so hang on the line appreciate
where your heart is at we're going to
give you the get clear assessment which
is like a a compass and then the book
from paycheck to purposes the guide to
help you climb up the mountain hang on
the line Austin I'll get that for you
thank you so much for calling don't move
more Ramsey show coming right up
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show where we help
you win in your life specifically your
money life your work life and your
relationship life I'm Ken Coleman
Christina Ellis is my colleague and we
are here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five to jump in on the conversation uh
we are
hiring and I feel like everybody's
hiring but we are definitely hiring
here's a fact about Ramsey solutions
that we're very very proud of we've
never laid anyone off now we've had to
fire some Duds but we don't lay people
off so that's nice for the past 30 years
we've been doing what we preached we run
a cash based business which means we
budget for everything that includes
salaries and comp for our team members
you deserve the right to work for
somebody you can trust and you can trust
us while other people are firing we're
still hiring
and we have several open roles on our
Marketing sales and Technology teams so
we need people like you to join us we're
way more than a radio show we help
people build real well do work they love
and create relationships in a common
sense but counter-cultural way that
sounds like a mission that you want to
be part of we'd love to have you apply
check out all the open roles check out
all the open roles rather at
ramseysolutions.com careers
ramsaysolutions.com
careers and if you want to get noticed
I would tell you go to kencoleman.com
download the free resume guide and use
the template because our resume template
does tend to get noticed that's all I'm
gonna say it's not good there you go all
right Christina you got an update
um of sorts we are standing by with
baited breath to see what is going on
with uh the loan forgiveness program the
Supreme Court what do you got for us
y'all it started today February 28th it
is the day that student loan forgiveness
is going before The Supreme Court so it
feels like we have waited 83 years for
anything to move on this and you're
gonna wait 83 more years in my humble
opinion we'll see it is finally time for
at least arguments to be heard and
hopefully some decision to be made and
just in an article was posted because it
started this morning and the headline
says Supreme Court majority signals
skepticism over Biden's student loan
forgiveness you think it's interesting
it says the conservative majority
signaled deep skepticism Tuesday about
Biden's plan to wipe out 400 billion in
student loan debt for tens of millions
of Americans suggesting the president
overstepped his powers under the law
really
tell us your opinion again I'm just
providing sound effects so far
during the course of more than three
hours of closely watched arguments the
justices prodded the Biden
Administration for answers about why the
student loan plan was different from
other emergency policies the White House
attempted to implement in the wake of
the covid-19 pandemic but were struck
down in one series of troubling signs
for the plan the Chief Justice
questioned a central premise of Biden's
argument that the president has the
authority to cancel student loans
without explicit Authority from Congress
he doesn't it's getting spicy y'all so
there's this thing called the
Constitution that you didn't tune in to
hear about but if you'd ever like to
know send me an email and I'll give you
guys a crash course on this lovely
document if you can't tell Ken Ken has
an opinion no but I'm being a really
good boy right now
focused uh don't hold your breath is my
point and by the way I've been saying
this yeah for the record Dave and I when
it first came out we were very strong on
this it's not going to happen and and
the number one reason why not going to
happen is because if it was if it was
going to happen the Biden Administration
would shut down the federal student loan
program because they're continuing to
give out loans so it doesn't smell right
look right if you and we've been that's
ridiculous we've been saying from the
beginning keep paying off these loans
there's not interest occurring right now
this is the time to think about it but
if you've been waiting this is the time
where they're deliberating and I hope
you again can feel that wake up call
that it's dicey it's dicey we don't know
what's going to happen but it's not
looking promising we will keep you
updated as things come about it's not
expected that a decision will be reached
immediately this could be a little time
but we'll keep you posted I'm posting
updates on my Instagram we'll tell you
updates here on the show tell people
your Instagram handle at I am Christina
Ellis there you go Christina with a K so
yeah we'll keep you posted y'all and I
know there's a lot of people fan feeling
anxiety about it but hopefully that can
come to rest soon one way or another we
will have a decision I'm trying to tell
people go ahead and forget it you're not
going to get your loans forgiven go
ahead and start paying it off pay it off
I don't mind being wrong it's not gonna
happen though all right let's go to the
phones Casey joins us in Phoenix Arizona
Casey how can we help
hi guys hey so I recently made a
decision that felt like I had to make
my mom she has a way of making me feel
like I'm doing something wrong unless
it's not the way she's doing it
so did you say you had to make this
decision
I felt I felt like I had to and you know
I'm working on that with myself because
mom made her feel like how old are you
Casey yeah how am I and how old am I I'm
28.
you're a grown woman
and you know you're growing I know like
you have got to get to the point where
you get over disappointing your mom
because based on what you said and the
way you're acting I believe you 100 and
I'm just gonna say something that may
hurt your feelings when you need to hear
it your mom is manipulating you
it's you know I
yeah yeah
yeah
she doesn't get to do that anymore
she's going to love you even when you
disappoint her because you've been a
really good girl growing up and you're a
pretty great lady as an adult true or
false
might not we don't know the mom and
boundaries are still healthy fair you
know what that's a very good point but
my I just I don't think that do you and
you and your mom have a fairly healthy
relationship outside of this kind of
stuff
no no
not that I you know one thing I wish is
that my parents were more of financial
awareness amongst us too and growing up
I'm suffering with that so tell us did
everything the wrong way so tell us this
financial decision that you felt
pressured into
okay well I'll take it back to October
October
debt free you know I'm peaceful mind I'm
feeling good I I drive a clunker it's
but it's getting by I have a credit card
though because my mom
he said you know you got to start credit
somehow if we get a credit card okay
fine but I'm going to be better with it
I don't want to be like Mom and have all
this credit debt so I pay it all off I
pay it currently today after listening
and you know trying to do my research I
don't need the credit card so I canceled
it today because I have zero balance yay
so I felt good about that it felt really
good we gotta hurry up because we only
got about two minutes with you so how
much what's the car situation November
lost my car November lost my clunker I
got a car loan
I have a car loan now it's 13 Grand I
don't feel good about it mom says I
should have got a higher car I should
have got it better yeah we don't care
what mom says anymore on this issue
what's the car worth so I have it the
cars 13k I bought it for 12 I got uh the
extended warranty for 29 I put four
grand down so now it sits at 13 one I
haven't even had a first payment yet due
the 25th what is the car worth could you
sell it today what could you sell it for
I I don't know I just got it I literally
just bought it from the dealership so
this is your only debt this is your only
debt correct this is my this is my only
day I have about 12 and a half in in
cash in the bank I have 44 of my
emergency funds I just lowered my 401k
to three percent should I turn the 401K
off and put everything to this car can I
pay off this car tomorrow but I don't
know what that'll do to the bank because
I've never just you know
so I'm gonna let Christina answer
because we got about a minute left so
pay attention she's going to walk you
through this so you said you have 12 000
in the bank and the loan is 13 000. is
that correct I got her on hold because
we're about to run into brakes yeah it
sounds like you have the cash she's
mentioned another 44 so it's like if you
have a cash right now I want you to pay
it off don't borrow from your 401k loan
I couldn't tell she was trying to hint
at that she's saying should I pause 401k
contribution to pay it off yes normally
yes but I think you can pay this
completely off by my math it was 9 000
you owe you got 12 plus another four pay
it off today today and then be debt free
go get yourself a cheap three thousand
four thousand and we're gonna gift you
FPU we want you to take it and stop
listening to Mom look this is your
financial Journey yes thank you so much
Casey for the call you got this don't
move more Ramsey show coming up
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman joined by my colleague Christina
Ellis we're here for you this hour
talking about your money your work and
your relationships triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Charlotte North Carolina now
Jessica joins us there Jessica how can
we help
hi um I am about ten thousand dollars in
debt I just recently started working in
September to try to begin paying this
off as I've been a stay-at-home mom
um we me and my husband recently
received taxes we received about eight
thousand dollars
um he paid his credit cards off with
that eight thousand dollars
um and we have some left and we have
about 2400 and he well we don't agree
um that I should pay what's left the
2400 on my cards he feels that it won't
help and it won't put a dent into
um where I'm at and so I just I don't
really know what to do I definitely
a mess and um okay so I'm not sure feels
like if I'm hearing you right there's a
lot of he and there's me
and I'm not hearing any we as that feels
like this is a big problem
yeah definitely well I'm confused
because you said I have 10 000 in debt
and then he paid off his 8 000 so yeah
you all have debt like if you have ten
thousand it's it's y'all's ten times
that's how you guys are playing this out
correct right correct and he doesn't
want you to take the remaining 2400 if I
heard you right and put it on your
credit card which would knock it down
from 10 to uh what is the math on that
68 6600 yeah so yeah how do we get to
this point like how how long have you
all been married
we've been married for
um 10 years
um I think we've gotten to this point
because I can be Reckless with money and
I have been and at the same time I have
grown just maybe not that much
um I'm still trying
um but I don't think I think it comes
down to him not trusting me yeah but
wait a second
um and I did my math wrong it would be 7
600 left if you put 2 400 on there so
why did he says that doesn't make a dent
that's a pretty good sized dent
yeah and uh and that would actually
actually leave me with four cards and
two of those cards I've already made
payment plan arrangements with those
credit card companies and um what does
he want you to do with that money
I he wants to save it because he thinks
it would be better for our family
because we're hoping to buy a house soon
because of their current renting and we
need to bring obviously what we're
paying monthly
um and living costs down how's your
relationship outside of the the this
issue
um I would say we have a pretty good
relationship
um we definitely
finances is definitely the hardest thing
to talk about together Jessica I'm going
to ask you a question I want you to be
really honest like take a you know take
a second to self-reflect you said that
he doesn't trust you with money are you
trustworthy at this point
at this point where I'm at yeah like
once this debt is paid off you're going
to close all these cards yes like
they're going to be gone forever and
you're never going back in debt
no never like have you had that I've had
at moment because we we've seen this
over and over again where people freak
out for a second they pay off their debt
and then they're back in it a year later
yeah no I definitely feel like I've been
here for a while that's why I got a job
in September okay
um so that is why I haven't been able to
catch up because I'm so behind that
minimum payments are 60 plus on nine
cards well and that's the thing is like
you feel the heat now but we want to
make sure even once you're caught up on
payments when you're not just like
feeling this heat that this continues as
a lifestyle so have you all taken
Financial Peace University yet
no okay that's step one and we'll gift
it to you hang on the line after the
call Austin will get it to you and
that'll be our gift to you guys and I
want you all to go through and if you
can find a local community so we have
Financial Peace University happening all
over the country and I want you all to
go in person yeah and go to this class
and walk it out every week at some point
you're going to have to literally cut up
your credit cards and be done with them
and I want you all to just get on the
same page because I think you're at that
spot where you're ready but this is this
is pretty deep and I mean he is probably
it's like I feel for both I feel you
know you're on the call and you're
wanting to move forward but he also has
legitimate reasons for being a little
bit nervous about this but but the thing
that I'm most concerned about is there's
no Unity on this and this is really
troubling I mean finances are the number
one cause of divorce and you guys you
guys are playing with fire and right I'm
curious you have separate bank accounts
as well we do we do now yes okay what do
you mean now
we didn't before
um before what
before I got a job I apologize
so when you got it so so you've done
stuff with money where he supposedly
doesn't or he doesn't trust you and then
you go out and get a job to try to deal
with some of the mess that you've made
and that's when he says let's get
separate accounts
yeah he ended up um getting his direct
deposit shifted somewhere else to make
sure that I wouldn't use it was that
during the phase where debt was racking
up
uh yeah because yeah okay so you guys
got to go see a marital counselor
yes I'm dead serious
because I don't want to unpack all this
for the audience because quite frankly
it doesn't matter we don't need to get
down deep right but you broke Trust
or or
you know what I think you broke trust
but I think he also used it
I could be wrong but both of you are
wounded and acting wounded and and and
his while you broke trust the right
response was not for him to go create a
separate account and now you guys have
these two separate things that's not the
right response I want to address that go
see a professional marital counselor and
let's get to the bottom of this because
if he wants to get healthy and you guys
are healthy and every other area of your
marriage then he's going to willingly do
this and you can rewind this and he can
watch this on YouTube but I'll just tell
you bro uh yes she may have wounded you
and you you lost trust but it's not okay
for you to now all of a sudden create
more separation two wrongs don't make a
right and and I get some marital
counseling and I'd shove all those
accounts together I would also tell you
to call these people today when you get
off this phone call and close the cards
okay literally close the accounts
you don't have to pay them off to close
them close them cut the credit cards up
you're never going back to this again
you got to fight for your marriage you
got to fight for your husband's heart
you guys got to fight for Unity on this
do you understand what I'm saying like I
don't want to sugarcoat this I'm not
like getting all uh worked up for no
reason like this is serious serious
stuff do you understand what I'm saying
yeah
yeah and if this stuff isn't okay your
marriage isn't okay like even just with
Ken asking the question of like how is
your marriage outside like it's not okay
if this isn't okay because this is just
like a symptom there's distrust there's
all of these different things going on
and I'm right there with you you need a
counselor and I think in this process
like you're both gonna have to really be
humble like I think you both have your
fists up and you guys you're defensive
and you're cautious and you're
distrusting and it's like this for this
to win for you all to win with your
money like it's going to take humility
with both of you you both are gonna go
we've both done things wrong like we're
both wrong we both have made mistakes we
both have been distrusting and let's
forgive what's happened obviously work
through it with a counselor but at some
point you will have to reach a spot
where you say I forgive you and he
forgives you and then you go let's start
from here like all all the shame all the
guilt all the bad things that have
happened in our past that's behind us
and now we're gonna build like we're
gonna build strong and we're gonna build
fresh and we're not gonna hold all that
stuff against each other yeah Jessica
hang on the line we're going to get you
into Financial Peace University as our
gift and
um let's let's commit let's do whatever
it takes for the two of you to go
through this let's also get to some
marital counseling this stuff is all
stuff that you can overcome I don't want
the seriousness of my tone to convey
that it is uh not something you can
overcome but it is very serious that we
overcome it and there are uh many many
people who can help you all certainly in
the Charlotte area let's let's get you
in an fbu class let's also get some
counseling all at the same time I would
treat this as trauma because it is so
thank you for the call hang on we'll
take good care of you
uh folks the numbers don't lie
when you aren't on the same page with
your spouse on money it creates a
tremendous Rift in your relationships
and it is the cause of Many Many of a
divorce so don't just treat this as mine
and yours it's ours don't move more of
your calls coming right up this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague
Christina Ellis
today's scripture of the day Proverbs 21
3 to do righteousness and Justice is
more acceptable to the Lord than
sacrifice our quote today
Dr Martin Luther King Jr the time is
always right to do
what is right
the man had a way with words and pathos
that I just don't know if we'll ever see
again uh I believe he could have read
the phone book and gave people
goosebumps you know just a phenomenal
phenomenal Communicator great stuff
there all right let's get back to the
phones Dawson is joining us now in
Lansing Michigan Dawson how can we help
uh yeah so I'm a high school senior and
I'm kind of looking to go into college
next year debt free
my questions on I've been applying for
several scholarships for school and so
my question was
um so my faith is a big part of my life
and I was just wondering like
uh and how open I should be about it
like when I write like scholarship essay
yeah do you have an example of like a
question that you were considering
answering with a faith-based answer
um so yeah so there was one question
that said um
like describe a period of like personal
growth in your life and
I had a young life Camp I really
experienced kind of a turning point in
my life and decided to take my Christian
faith more seriously
so I was wondering like kind of could I
talk about that I was like the answer
yeah that's such a good question and
there's not really a right or wrong
answer because I mean a scholarship
application in those essays they're
trying to find out who you are it's
about writing about your personal story
and what's important to you so if that
was a big part of your life and that is
the experience you want to talk about
then I would say talk about it now the
bigger question on should you talk about
faith in a scholarship application just
in general I mean we're in a tricky
place in the world right now where where
there's just so many different opinions
about religion and political issues and
all these different things I would say
and this may be I'm scared I'm gonna get
in trouble like don't write just to try
to preach at the judge like if you're
like man I'm going to try to write
through my scholarship application to
try to make some point one of the things
I've talked about in one of my books is
there's a lot of political things that
you could get into in scholarship
applications there's a lot of religious
things there's a lot of gender things
and culture things and all these
different things and you know I do talk
about being mindful of your audience and
you know just being smart like if there
is a political issue that you feel
passionate about I wouldn't say that a
scholarship application is your place to
try to make some sort of political point
but if your religious experience was a
huge part of your life journey and you
going to this experience transformed you
then I wouldn't hide it
I would just go ahead and write about it
okay yeah yeah
um would you have any other like kind of
tips or advice like growing retiring or
scholarship essays yeah does she does
she all right so where do I start I
should order your book okay good oh good
so Chris you know like how much money
did you I want people to hear this and
you would never just say it so tell
people you did all this research applied
you wrote wrote wrote to your fingers
blood how much money did you get I won
over a half a million dollars a million
dollars in scholarships and man I could
talk about this literally all day it
gets me so excited he's ready give him a
couple things what does Dawson need to
do right now yeah well you're already
motivated you're calling here getting
tips on it treat it like a part-time job
like set a goal it's easy for people to
get really stoked about scholarships on
a weekend and then apply for a bunch of
scholarships and then get burned out and
then not apply after that so I want you
to set a goal over six months like even
if it's just you apply for four a week
you know over six months that's going to
be a ton of scholarships like over over
100 scholarships so it's like you know
set a goal where you can carry it out
over time and with essays specifically
so I feel like essays that's an area
where a lot of people just kind of
either get freaked out or like Stomps
them because a lot of people don't want
to write it forgive me I'm gonna I
really don't know this is gonna be great
for other people yeah so is this where
you're applying maybe to a foundation or
to some private entity and they're
saying send us an essay and then based
on the merits or whatever in the essay
we'll decide whether or not we have we
allow or we uh award you scholarship
money yeah it's part of the application
yeah so there are many factors they're
looking at and one part is essays and
one of the cool things that a lot of
people don't realize when they sit down
to do scholarship applications let's say
you're applying for 100 scholarships the
idea of writing 100 essays that sounds
overwhelmed I just broke out into a cold
sweat struggling but you don't have to
write 100 essays so I typically
recommend that students write you know
between five and ten essays a lot of
these applications are asking the same
question or a similar question so okay
so you just mix them around you recycle
them basically so you have your core
essays about seven core essays and then
each time you have a new application you
kind of go through your Rolodex of
essays and say okay which essay is
closely related to this question and
then you can reuse it on future
applications so it's like once you've
filled out a few scholarship
applications the process gets easier you
can reuse those materials how do you
stand out well one of the things that
first came to mind to you just was like
writing these different essays
especially if you're talking about your
faith get feedback ask several people
for feedback on these essays so whenever
I was applying for one of the most
competitive scholarships that I won I
literally asked like seven people to
look at my essays I asked English
teachers I asked I asked mentors I
wanted people to tell me does this
resonate with you does this move you
because these scholarship judges I think
it sounds like they're these big fancy
official people sitting on some
Untouchable Hill but they're real people
like you know they're alumni from
different scholarships they're teachers
they're people who care about students
so it's like if you can get your essay
solid enough that it impacts your
teacher that it impacts your parents
your coaches then it's like that is
going to be a really solid essay that
has a higher likelihood of actually
impacting the judges reading it and that
sounds like a lot of effort but again
once you have those solid essays those
can be recycled for future applications
all right Dawson real quick where are
you where are you wanting to go or do
you have some ideas what's what's the
path I'd love to just kind of hit this
rock star Christina with a with a real
life scenario and see what she spits out
to you so what are you thinking
yeah so right now
um I'm planning on going to a small
Christian College
um so maybe like there's one called
Taylor University sure one called North
Greenville in South Carolina okay um
those are times
what are you pursuing what do you think
you want to pursue
yeah so right now
um like mechanical engineering is like
probably my number one and then maybe
like civil or chemical kind of below
that
so like one thing is like I don't have a
ton of like I guess experience aside
from like math classes I've taken to
kind of like apply for like stem I guess
more stem scholarships yeah so but
that's kind of like my passion is kind
of like I like math and science a lot
all right so Christina I know I'm
putting you on the spot but again this
is like yeah you could wake up at three
in the morning and spit out a couple
things based on what little bit of
information he gave you where is he
looking what type of things is he trying
to look for are you a senior right now
or a junior
I'm a senior so it's kind of a little
bit late yeah you're in crunch time have
you applied to these colleges yet
yeah yeah oh yeah so I've gotten into
most of them and then I think I'll
probably have to have like around
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars okay
for a full year okay and with these stem
scholarships are you seeing requirements
that you have certain stem experience or
what's kind of holding you back from
applying for these
um so none of them like like require
that but some of them kind of like asked
like okay like what what are stem like
activities that you've been involved in
in high school I would encourage you to
like dig deep and be creative because a
lot of times I've talked to people who
think they don't have certain
experiences I talk a lot about like how
to build out your resume and they're
like man I don't have a lot to put on my
resume and I'm like well have you ever
volunteered at your church and they're
like yeah I serve I serve every Sunday
and I'm like do you ever serve in your
community and they're like yeah I
babysit for my neighbor all the time and
it's like those are all things you can
put in your scholarship resume so I
encourage you when thinking about stem
things are there any things that you
have done that could at least show some
glimmer of interest and then also with
these essays consider talking about
maybe something you want to do in the
future in stem so if you don't have a
ton to talk about looking back
historically dream about the future like
I would like to change the world this
way I'm really passionate about
impacting people this way oh I can give
you something now finally all right so
here it is young man here's what I want
you to do I want you to take what
Christina just said and as it relates to
engineering and all that kind of world I
want you to to in your essay write about
a problem that you want to solve the
people that that solution will impact
share a narrative a dream a vision that
will be huge because they want to give
people a chance to change the world and
say they had something to do with it hey
we got to get out of here before we do
Christina Ellis great hour James Childs
are fearless Captain uh behind the glass
and the support crew thank you guys and
you America thank you for listening this
is the Ramsey Show
hey it's Ken if you like what you heard
in this episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsey Baby
Steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation again
that's ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]